yeah yeah we're good
well good chinnough chinnough Jim okay
um what's up dude
what happened our energy go down low
energy the way you sit gives me low
energy oh well I tend to be a little bit
cross-legged on yourself got it no no I
gotta go with the professional I was
gonna say it's layered is layered
it's layered up now do you get it done
it there's a woman named Camilo comes to
my house who's a fan of the fighter and
kid her boyfriends a fan of our vodka Oh
was yeah and she she she brings it down
for me
it's just that what happens to me is I'm
in my hotel room on the road and I go
I've seen you cut your own need a
haircut riding and doing things need a
haircut and then I start cutting you I
don't know I just thought well you don't
with your hair you can't just go to any
one else like I can kind of [ __ ] with
anyone yeah for me it can be a disaster
it takes too much often never coming
yeah where they cut the to short along
here and I'm like listen sir I have a
very long head so now I look like Johnny
long head this lady
uh-uh not the lady from habit can either
not - no she just she said you guys
there's another guy named Daniel who's
fantastic who cuts my hair
yes Victor one dude he's so busy he's
never around but he's so great he just
kind of goes yeah I told you my dad
passed away yeah yeah it's a heart
attack for kids so now you had a new guy
forget his name but he's [ __ ] Puerto
Rican speaks zero English really Puerto
Rican huh definitely involved in some
other business by [ __ ] with him mm-hmm
I don't know where else to go it's tough
bad I had a guy she cuts his own hair I
could do it you can do what I can do
sweet fades I can't have you it would be
weird just feeling it cut here it sounds
a little kid my mom taught me Wow I cut
my son's hair buys to a two year it
layer me up like this I could little I
do phase with cliffs I have a nice he's
all about faith not okay I can't do a
thing I'm too old for that and also you
don't wanna shave this side of my hair
look terrible I don't look I don't have
used to have a shade head for a long
time yes as far back as I can remember
I've had as far back I've had bad hair
when I was 13 years old
my friend held like touched my hair and
he goes that feels like hey I was like
right now I had bad hair long blonde and
bad my if I here keeps going out well
now I don't know because I can get it a
little bit in college we decided grow
here I mean in my industry from jew-fro
really up Jewish bro
yeah I look like a little Dicky if it
keeps going my son Sears curliest [ __ ] -
yeah now it's the summer I like that cut
it like to shave it down shave it down
he looks good with little looks like
your Navy SEAL oh yeah yeah his grandmas
mom hey Donna know about it really
they like the crazy long hair I don't
know you gotta keep it short
well that's the show thank you guys
thanks guys my grandfather said it yeah
your ears aren't Sean dude have you
years Sean
here's our Sean too long my god okay cut
it short I'm are shaving my head that
was I shave my head all the time if I
could but my I do it now my eyes are too
devastating hello and I do it now
looking at our army market I want to
shave my head don't shave your head
Brian you won't look like Aubrey Marcus
you don't shave your head yeah you see
other like alpha dudes and you wanna
yeah I want to be tough looking yeah now
you're thinking oh you know be a guy
what is your regular guy secret how
about lifting hey yeah how about last
night
Jeremiah Watkins cut his hair heat so he
had long hair you know D'Elia cut his
hair he had long hair yeah and I see
Jeremiah go how do you get yet to Daliya
cutting us what is from which people
egos but why I yet the Thalia cut you
guys both had the same hair now you have
the exact same way just cut show us no I
did mine before I yeah I know but he's
so much more famous so that would be the
D'Elia cats all did you I could hide
under his nose if it rained well
Jeremiah yeah you don't want you me and
him at a cocaine chair mine's got the
biggest nose and hands-down the biggest
nose in the hands-down the biggest nose
in comedy and he should have his own he
should have his own TV show on the nose
channel and he can't swim backwards in a
pool no but he sure is hair long because
if he keeps it short I would imagine
it's going to accentuate his wonderful
purpose there's the new cut look at that
Naza he's such a good guy talented - he
nights this guy baloney get the face
he's got a he's got a nose on him hit me
boy dropped a straight-up album oh
really
yeah like comedies talented man talented
dude yeah that's right gosh I got to do
a show I keep he keeps asking me and I'm
usually out of town or something dude
yeah you're definitely not is that it's
Tuesday nights you know so no one's on
the road on Tuesday nights but anyway at
least you lied a little bit I am so uh I
you might have the biggest nose anyone I
know yeah yeah
there is though got an eight you know
Asians don't have big noses
well name an Asian with a big notes
why'd ya long no is there ever an Asian
with a long no that's a good observation
never know they all got box or nose yeah
what bro like flat wide it's like a
bottle you got a bunch of it I can't be
involved that's not racism this racist
this sloka
racist how true is not racing your agent
dude's a box your nose I don't see you
this racist I say they have almond eyes
you're his boss right now so he's gonna
have the same you know it's open
conversation yeah it's not racist I
think we would say it's broader features
no absolutely not
boxer knows boxer knows let's see if we
can see Asians with I think usually if
you see an Asian with a long nose it's a
it's a combination Asians just hear me
out here before we get in this Asians
have box noses and big calves
okay now not Japanese people you will
see Japanese people with noses like that
that's probably the biggest you'll see
yeah yeah you'll see Japanese that's a
stork in Japan while the Japanese have
but in general fairly it's not racist
that's like saying it's not a bad thing
yeah you don't want a long [ __ ] nose
yeah no I mean I like black guys have
big dicks okay that races yeah no that's
awesome yeah well well what would be
better is if you were to say we don't
know if black guys have big dicks but if
you were to say black guys have small
dicks most of us would go I you know
I've seen some porn and I have some
friends and I would have to say that
from my experience
that's not a blanket stay from you
everyone's experience a this Asians have
long very long Romanesque pointy noses I
would have to say Brennan you're off
you're a little love here I haven't seen
that as much as I've seen smaller noses
not Boxer noses because Boxer noses are
noses that have been punched flat yeah
wide flat and wide yeah I don't see a
problem when I think what you're doing
this race no it's it's a did that offend
you in any bit no no what you're way
better than ours sometimes the truth in
this environment get your podcast
cancelled this is the last podcast guy
can't throw this podcast okay I forgot
about that no I think I think that I
think it's noted that there are features
in general certain agents have box or
nose is wide and you know short big
calves small wee wees I don't know I
haven't done a measure of the wee wees I
told you that that urologist has seen
30,000 dick we looked at up Greek guys
have dicks
she said the biggest but we looked at
other that's not true Wow maybe a very
experienced know though know this this
research the research they've done they
kind of you know they went pretty deep
into it yeah
yeah I don't know but in general we know
this you know it's not yeah I would
imagine like stereotypes exist for a
reason
in general the pretty spot-on yeah I
would imagine that a lot of times if you
have a group of people that have not
bred a lot with other races and it tends
to be the gene pool tends to be
specifically that you're gonna get
consistent features where you get like a
mix is when you've got you know people
in certain parts of the world that are
breeding with everybody you know like
look at the southern Italians the the
Moors came in everybody there there's
all kinds of breeding that goes on there
so you have a wide variety and a
different look everywhere you go I would
imagine Europe is like that like you're
like like partly cute like Tongans or
like Polynesians giant cats yeah show me
a [ __ ] Polynesian with small cats do
you know why it was just like let's put
your life
fives on them now you're not finding
that no there's your thick bone you're
not for pal pazzo Polynesian people also
wide knows it correct they don't they
have boxer noses as well and that's a
good thing
and what cocaine knows and 60 minutes
said if you are a Samoan or tongue and
you have a fifty five times you're fifty
five times more likely to be able to
play in the NFL smaller pool who are
then if you are of Northern European
descent in other words that there's a
certain bone structure a certain density
a certain like you know then the the
black guys in [ __ ] Clark Gable
Florida go hold my [ __ ] hot wing
because I'm there odds are way higher
and this is the racist podcast from
Brennan job it depends though and that
that's a much smaller pool though bra
there's a really good book to read
called the sports gene by David Epstein
who wrote look at the size that dude
I want that tattoo the sports gene is a
really good book about this oh yeah this
knows we get his so for war that Kyle
beat your [ __ ] ass yeah I don't know
man I just look at his nose mmm-hmm they
don't have pointy noses right now is my
guess also here's another thing agents
flat asses in general yeah yeah I think
Samoans may not have no let's have
good-sized ass they do yeah they're did
they're thick their Hinds are thinning
yeah they got a move please get off this
guy caused by the nut I want to the
process yeah get them dude yeah well I
mean there would you know this chin and
cat like flat asses big calves wide
noses the ass thing also depends on how
like closer to the equator you get cuz
like I noticed the browner the Asian the
thicker they tend to get so like East
Asian like Chinese versus like Southeast
Asian like the like ties aren't [ __ ]
this not it's not a communist poison the
trick you you'll see some asses on Thai
women but you'll really see some asses
on Filipino reps I'm knowing thought
women with cakes and been there true and
been there and enjoy myself you know
yeah you I've seen some Philip
that our Kaiser yes the st. cakes
hey hey that's what we see on the street
you got some Filipino Filipinos together
wide noses they're notorious for that
yes really no story yeah I feel like
it's uh it's an advantage like I wish I
had chins nostril I wouldn't say why
does that say you see the chins brain I
take cute doses I'd see why there's a
bunny nose that's not a wide nose that
everyone knows there you go I'd be a
white now okay me now you know debate at
has a button nose yeah I don't think it
has a wide nose yeah but if you look at
at different angles
I can't think there's so much cuter
agent knows this more I like it there's
I like it yours yours looks like you
have a dick hanging between two ah yeah
that's the way bar you eating I think
O'Brien yeah like Squidward yes yes fine
sponge well I know this grown young
Brian had a a sharp nice all young brain
but uh Jesus that Filipino again yeah if
that's why he knows I'll take it again I
wish I had a wide nose I was if I was
gonna have surgery be a wider you ever I
can breathe but you got a big old nose
yeah yeah you gotta breathe now do you I
know is this completely different you go
back and look like when I was on The
Ultimate Fighter out of very sharp
pointy nose did look very Jewish you got
a very well people have asked me if
you're Jewish
yeah Jewish women go as he drew cuz shop
could be a Jewish name or very German
there's right here man was shop yeah you
know that no look it up okay but again
I'm not please
uh I think maybe brothers the original
Samoan my nose was broke in that picture
that exact picture see but my nose is
pointing are there look at that nope
it's head surgery already there may be
sure maybe
yeah it's pointy ER young man there
that's good tation swole
steroids got some tits on you yeah crazy
pictures look at that was he was he cool
before the fighter were you talking Mary
she looks like he's just smile and I I
don't know bro [ __ ] know I have no
idea what's up man I guess I don't know
yeah my nose used to be way more point
here though flattens out over time
your nose and ear are the only things
that grow yeah ah your nose and ears
that's yeah it keeps growing I think so
I thought true or is that uh man no
that's true that's true
Asians people's nose and ears don't keep
growing I think they do I think we would
look ridiculous with bigger houses
though that's why we like you would look
ridiculous if you had like a smaller
nose maybe cartilage that's the plastic
last seventy years and noses continues
won't stop growing after puberty muscles
and fat cells also stop dividing but
cartilage is less like stuff in ears and
noses cartilage continues to grow until
the day you die I need to is there a way
with oh but the earlobes is long gate
from gravity I don't want any of that
sir
well you got it I got lobes on me
yeah nuts I'll get them trimmed up you
do that can I have my lobes shortened do
your eyes and ears the same time I will
do my eyes and that makes the ears of
Kievan larger oh so there's not like
getting like this he's got not hanging
down the band yeah yeah but I don't this
minor [ __ ] up from wrastlin yeah I
wonder if they'll well no they it just
said it doesn't matter it grows oh wow
so that guy just his nose just yeah is
no longer its way go sin but are you I
like is your is your mom and dad their
nose is larger then they just look they
look the same right well my dad my dad's
looking older my mom looks almost the
same
yeah but the Sears nose is the same he's
face changed quite a bit so yeah I would
say everything is different now his ears
are more like my dad I can just look at
him and go well they are bright that's
the way go as you get older you start to
look more like your dad you become more
like your parents I hate to say it like
when I shaved I might add the spot on
yeah yeah and you'll start to become
like him probably more and more who are
you more like your mom your dad my dad
for sure yeah but I think we're heading
for a time when you're gonna be able to
do all kinds of stuff with your
appearance verse sit in chair yeah
I hope you're right yeah 100% already
are well if there's a pill that made
everyone shred it don't you think the
new thing would be to be fat well I
would imagine that like if everyone
could be
when that winstrol well no like if you
just take a pill or there's some
procedure get where you just shred it is
available to the masses don't you think
there would be a flop on the other side
we're being like a little thick and fat
and chunky with school well that's a
good cuz you want to be different
because as we're able to genetically
become perfect what happens to variation
that's what I'm saying right like if
every dude goes oh I shouldn't be
shredded aren't girls in like god I'm
looking for that fake boy or it's so
sick of these shredded dude well it
would become just as normal as yes well
it just becomes it be nothing that's all
same few interests whatever they still
want some difference uh-huh
when you see a guy russkis gonna be
there physically gifted and shredded you
go that's Wow yeah it's different now
yeah a few guys reading just a freak
athlete people I go he's he's an outlier
but if you can pick that I'm sure every
dad's gonna pick that for his son so
it's like alright every girl's gonna
have a blood ass thick lips and a
[ __ ] said it okay but here's my
question that the problem with that is
so you can say you genetically can say
okay I want my kid to be and you're
we're getting there I want my kid to be
64 to 35 and all fast-twitch muscle cool
well you really want is you're saying I
want my son to be a professional athlete
right and probably a and that's really
tricky too because that's one kind of
sport I don't know if that body type is
best for tennis or golf whatever it
might be
they probably won't play tennis or golf
oh yeah yeah but so then I would say to
you Brennan okay so your kid I can make
your kid I can have him built like
ridiculous linebacker do you want to
play in football pro football like we
know they'd be out still a lot of
choices to ask yourself but if they can
do that they can salvage the brain yeah
sure salvage the brain is a big question
yeah which they can't do the right thing
they can't do that's right they have no
idea what to do with it so there's still
there would still be a lot of questions
I even now if I could do it if there was
available and they said all your sense
can be 6-4 240 pound right at 4-4 and
the 40 I wouldn't do it yeah I'd still
leave it up to the big man upstairs
because it's not what are you supposed
to do and also the variety and variation
and your lack of in whatever always is
most of us compensate so I'm not built a
certain way I become a comedian Steven
jobs isn't big
to be a professional right I was put on
the earth to be a comedian
Steven jobs upon the earth to be a
visionary and then an [ __ ] you know
whatever but I mean he was a visionary
and gave us the goodies so whatever that
personality is which has its liabilities
and strengths yeah he probably would
have done that if yeah we need part we
need variety but if everyone was six six
to forty you're gonna get that again
maybe yeah so so all of a sudden it just
becomes what we all are and the world
kind of gets tailored to your height and
stuff
crazier yeah it's all those questions
that we're gonna be faced with variety
is very important can't you want kids
yeah someday you're so young does your
man what kids yeah I just I don't know
if I'm ready for a kid like how old are
you again I'm 23 I'm 20 before we got
time yeah it's at least 7 years yeah you
got the idea of having my own kids
freaks me out yeah your age where she
freaks every 23 oh she did I tell you
this last time about how they cured the
boy in the bubble disease you see this
so you know how kids are born without an
immune system they have to live in them
you know and they die your kiddos and
they did a movie about it with John
Travolta in the 70s but it was based on
a true story and the kid lived too late
was 12 lived in a bubble his parents
could only touch him through gloves kids
hurting horrible horrible so check this
out so it used to be you'd be born with
that and your kid would die you know and
by the way you'd have three or four
years of the kid in a bubble and you
could touch him and it's really really
sad they get a cold night now they just
did tech this is so [ __ ] nuts they
took with CRISPR cast 9 which is gene
editing they took these little toddlers
and infants they took I believe the HIV
virus the AIDS virus they stripped it of
its pathogen and equalities like they of
what gives you aids and then they put a
gene in where the pathogen would be I'm
bastardizing this but this is the excuse
and they shot it into back into the kid
the virus infected the kid but instead
of infecting it with the HIV virus and
in fact for the kid with an immune
system that's so they eight kids now
have fully functioning immune systems
and they're completely normal how many
kids have it though in the world
well you know as always it affects
almost only boys and it's it was always
a rare thing but it's enough was enough
but now that's that's and now they just
did that with leukemia this kid had
leukemia and they cured his leukemia
with the same thing this is the new
frontier it's [ __ ] incredible
it's horribly okay if your kid had that
yeah but there be able to fix it even
certain skits no not schizophrenia but
epileptic seizures so so some kids get
epilepsy seizures like small ones over
even when they're sleeping that's all I
thought that yeah yeah yeah only this is
a condition where even when yes yeah
that's my son Ham was sleeping
oh we did okay so by the CBD oil is
really yes yeah well so so there are
certain things where CBD and the nerve
the viruses some that does makes it yeah
kids pass away
now now now in I think a few judges also
his kid passed away because of it like
12 that's so many seizures finding the
body and in vitro now they can they can
change this now now they can actually
fix your brain they seem a new frontier
man [ __ ] amazed skids
yeah Cheney you know my kids I think
it's I'm running late now so you're only
540 yeah no 42 yeah 42 dude in my first
case I was 41 bro really yeah what is
your second I'm 45 well there you go
that time yeah yeah the tunnels on this
wall there's still like light at the end
but we don't have any perspectives I
mean that we don't yeah I know a lot
specs right now I'm the kid but I'd
rather have it for my parents than me if
I don't have a kid my brother didn't
have a kid yet he's older than me if I
don't have it then where our names gone
damn dude yes sir busting nuts and girl
gotta bust nuts at least one yeah and
it's got to get boy there's someone out
there who will do it with you
just who the [ __ ] of it there hey guy
Thank You Bryan
does it make sense how he doesn't have a
girl get your [ __ ] together well cuz
that's okay guys guys can't get pregnant
and so gay busting ass isn't so good
once it comes out to us and we go we
don't care and we knew all along we love
you anyway it'll be fine
I want a gay gay pretty it'll really be
an amazing grinder would be
yeah it'll be an amazing will be so
diverse so even though you are racist we
still have a gay we're still good I
don't why hey gay and then hey engage
and you know producer so yeah I like
that I mean there's no I god there's I'd
love to get inside your head Jim there's
no prospects there's nothing like not
even a kernel there's definitely girls
that if I wanted to like a date yeah I
just don't feel like dating right
China's yeah you don't have the energy I
don't know what it is I'm not like
really light its dick Hartford Kitson I
don't know where it is but I mean maybe
when I get back in shape I'll be more
motivated are you actually get back here
about how you look naked definitely okay
yeah well you know what are ways to do
like old trim O'Brien never stops
working out if you can always work out
you know I've been working out now okay
so you think when you work out and get
to a certain physical that's the least I
could do
but you think that's why you're you
don't I mean no that's definitely one
part I don't think a lot of girls care
dude you're at all and I can and you're
intelligent and talented yeah be cute I
start the dialogue in dates you don't
have to get your dick on the first date
like get to know someone for a while to
get in shape but at least start the
journey most job is a certified personal
trainer ask him some advice he'll give
you a workout or no I've been a routine
I've worked out before I've gotten
really lean and all that stuff find out
it do remember he used to be 300 pounds
he knows how to workout lose weight you
need our advice it's just I don't know
it's a start down the yellow brick road
of rejection I do talk what do mean talk
talk to people you know this drives me
crazy like rabbits right you know it's
fascinating but very frustrating yeah
yeah you know you can you can kind of
have a lot of stuff if you make the
choice just to take the actions but Jim
does have a lot of stuff but I'm very
sick yeah I talked to this guy and I
said I said why haven't you worked out
in five years and he goes well you want
the real answer I go yeah he goes I just
been in a rut and I was like hey hey man
I I will not talk to you anymore if you
say
if you got I'll just be a little worked
out actually Myers do he wants to work
out I know he didn't yeah he say that
cuz you're there pressure no he said I
know I hurt you any cuz I've just been
an erotic oh that's not an excuse what
do you say that cuz here there be no no
because he said to me he goes I want to
get in shape like it was bothering him
as well because he go again right well
that but that but that's right I said do
I go that's actually what I said I go
hold on hold on that's not the reason
like what's what's why don't you want to
what's really going on I you know this
is their their reasons that are deeper
right but sometimes you know for me I
don't actually go into the psychology of
it I just started doing it like I'll
just [ __ ] take the action sometimes
getting into the why is man that's a
maze I just start doing it and I feel
better when I do it right yeah but I
mean chill out go [ __ ] if you work out
I'm just I'm just saying just start on
the journey of finding a campaign you
have a little red eye old and alone the
jokey I found like two girls in the last
year that I was kind of interested in
and what happened you knew one of them
too we went to a show oh when I'm right
was it which show we were well I don't
want to get into too much because she
found out we were talking about but we
don't yeah we hung out after yeah at a
bar as she was awesome
she was dope yeah not into you not into
me but she still wanted to hang out
which is weird because you're you're in
the friend zone
so okay she's out barely met her yeah
and also I don't want to put I'm not
saying her name but she got out of a
12-year relationship like a week or so
from that day oh there you go yes she's
trying then once once she was like you
know she's not sure I was like boom I'm
not yeah
what boom you're out maybe smoothie
Natalie old chin train choose your way
right back around too late there you go
come on back so he writes wrong yeah
Brett and I got a couple of couple dogs
you see what we do is you know wild dogs
like we give chase and then the dog gets
away but then we're like we'll just go
around this is flank take the long way
take the flank we're not
uh-uh nothing - I'm so stubborn that
your problem yeah that's been playing
nightmare to Diamond night rubber
yeah or so just because she was like out
of 12 you really ship not looking to get
married tomorrow you're I'm [ __ ] out
of here I think you probably have a yeah
yo are you ever completely a secret life
and I applied now I'm dying to know
yeah and who's the other girl chin
someone that I met at sort of a doctor's
office whoa oh that's when you were
getting your physical [ __ ] bring out
let's just say yeah my nose we're like
you ever runny nose she's like I dunno
the nose one was a bad one there's an
older lady but it was just I don't get
in too much detail because I think
people whenever I talk about people they
find out some friend listens to the show
friends and then it just kind of ruins
it but do nothing happen there so it
doesn't matter well we'll see oh you see
there's still a chance so you know me
there's a chance yeah what would be the
chance that Jenny and diem probably low
how long have you made any action
towards any plans anything I was really
close to doing it I'm getting a lot of
general what are the kid and friends I
was gonna invite her there but what
happened
that'd be great I didn't get a text back
from you bro from me yeah shut up
no you're the one sweater I couldn't get
in I could get on hauls literally no son
hey let's go hey chin you can always get
tickets he's gonna show up I'm just
saying it's not like we're gonna go chin
I look at he can't get into my show
that'll never happen and of course you
know that these are called excuses I
look at that as a university that we're
probably [ __ ] your nightmare this is
going on I gotta go through this and see
like a guy wants to take me skydiving
and I find every excuse not to do it cuz
I just don't feel like dying I get it
like I'm like Matt the shoot will the
shows on Thursday I don't have any text
from each in asking for tickets maybe
didn't go through then yeah that's
another sign [ __ ] dude
you can ask cat that's whole cat about
it to listen about it either way you're
not ready to date you want to be a light
on to you or you want to be with Phil or
whatever his name is and that's fine I
don't care
Brendan's the one who's [ __ ] giving
you a hard time for being I'm just
trying to get the [ __ ] bonus because
I don't want you know mysteries he
wanted to tell you what he watches he
just watches fishing fishing trapping
fish I mean a lot of it says we I feel
like we should break into his house one
day and you know frustrating man I'm
happy yeah all right well that's this is
all the current events man her in events
let's go to Corinna Van Dam okay so
Russell Wilson gifted all of his linemen
12k worth of Amazon stocks oh that's
pretty cool I was gonna go up
yeah he said that he was thinking about
different gifts to give them but he
wanted something that would last for him
his family and his children yeah he gave
them and no one else he did he bought
all of his girls masters all her songs
see her songs
oh all the masters and gift them to her
big deal yeah big deal when you own all
your own [ __ ] Wow
my boy clot when he played for the Rams
so he gave the it was Steven Jackson was
the running back was a [ __ ] monster
they went to the pro ball so he bought
all the starting offensive line and
tight end panerai watches it's just like
mmm I don't know probably ten thousand
dollar gift each give Andre Agassi and
Steffi Graf they would go this
restaurant all the time and this waiter
this Italian waiter was always working
really hard a really good guy and and
they kind of talked to him one time and
he said something about he's got he had
two kids ago you're always here he goes
I got two kids you know and I'm trying
to make money and a sick mom all the
stuff and they bought him Nike stock and
one day just said this is Nike stock and
this will take care of both your
children's education and everything else
need he started crying right at the
table that's a real [ __ ] gift man
like oh by the way your kids college no
debt for them yeah
don't worry about it school yeah Kurt
Warner I don't know if he still does it
but Kurt Warner when he was playing with
a huge you know him his wife's got to
restaurant and they just picked one
table with the family and that's awesome
every time he went out everything at
that next one yeah so three men in
Pennsylvania last year were arrested for
[ __ ] animals
and there were yeah there were three
guys they actually lived with a teenager
at the time the teenager was a 16 year
old boy they forced a 16 year old boy to
hold down the animals in this in like
little enclosure that they created
specifically to [ __ ] animals so the 16
year old kid would have to stand there
hold the animals in place while these
three men [ __ ] the animals there were
men involved but there was a terrier mix
three three the three adults thirty year
old men were the ones [ __ ] the
animals the 16 year old boy was forced
to hold the animal in place while it was
happening they could find out the 16
year old boy ended up going to the
police and reporting them dude this
includes a cow a goat nine horses like
an unknown amount of dogs and they did
specify that all of the horses were
female they did not specify B I feel
like the horses don't feel it but the
nor does the cow but a little dog that's
[ __ ] crimes against nature of Samedi
which is punished by 15 years in jail by
the way how do you get a job when you
come out of this what are you in for
I was [ __ ] dogs horses coalition
holdups
a corner the county michigan state
police were called to residents after
home owners saw when the dudes have an
intercourse with their dog on their
video system yeah that's a different guy
but someone he's like yeah there is this
guy who came over to his friends house
this is took place in Michigan he [ __ ]
the dog they found it on a security
camera and they reported it to the
police that way they didn't know any of
this was happening until they found the
footage yeah but I don't
how you like this is the conversation
with your fruit three friends you guys
how did you guys figure out you're into
[ __ ] it yeah you got yeah [ __ ] dog
that where they farmers are somewhat
their background yes they did have their
own plan they were all hanging around
and dudes like the cow like dude it's my
favorite yeah yeah those guys like dude
I'd love to do that I'm gonna how about
a dog I thought solutions 11 dogs got a
[ __ ] you know I mean this is how guys
are
how do you do like sure I go to prison
though for 15 years you know that's the
question probably not still just don't
let me around your dog so so it one of
the office of the horses like well so so
so gun laws so if a guy is taking this
is a terrible example but if a guy will
take a bat baseball bat and he was
beating your beloved dog to death with a
club and you had a gun and you shot him
you could go to jail for life because
technically the dog is considered
property it's not considered it not be
like your kid or something right it's
it's considered property so technically
the law would state I believe at least
in California because I talk to the gun
guy it's almost like he was beating
legally or your flat-screen TV as
opposed to dog
so yes his cruelty to animals which
carries its own penalty but for you to
shoot him so yeah here's my here's my
thing I don't know what's that have to
do it well in other words true because I
think dogs are considered property and
your [ __ ] property but there is
something called cruel to the animals
and bestiality is probably a lot because
you can't be cruel to the TV yeah
that'll long now now now that you're a
law is it and here's my question like
that lay just got a restaurant the
puppies yes
is it is it torture is it cruel and
unusual is it torture to the dog right
so is the dog crying as the dog in pain
because I don't think the horse dog how
much I notice they didn't consent well
they don't know how to your animal that
the consent laws don't apply to the
animals but love just but you can't rape
will you basically raping the dog right
yeah my friend caught a guy [ __ ] a
chicken in San Francisco his car yeah
he's a cop how about some alone
dudes man caught it caught I caught a
homely sag to chicken and could there be
a lower point in your life yet got
[ __ ] it well because a woman came up
and said that guy's doing something
weird under that blanket so my friend
walked over to the tool and the guy's
the guy was in his car didn't speak
English very well and he had a blanket
and he was doing something and my friend
said sir you gotta open the blanket of
guys no that's okay thank you guys
I gotta see what's under the blanket I
thought there was a chick here
tenderizing meat yes
well can't tenderize the chicken that's
the question what if you [ __ ] the
chicken and the chicken is dead if you
can kill a chicken
why can't you [ __ ] chicken that's the
question I'm really I mean this is like
I don't know man
you know factory farming the way they
cut the beaks off that's a form of
torture I'm sure most those chickens
rather get [ __ ] and you cut their baby
girl so again this is a very difficult
case sir because that's not that well
but did you go to jail so if you catch a
guy [ __ ] a horse and a a cow I'd
rather them do that than kids of course
but also we go I don't think the horse
and the cow feel that maybe they feel a
little bit of it so we're like yeah 15
years that seems like a long time well
if it helps he's also all three men are
also being charged for child abuse for
force forcing the sixteen-year-old kid
to stand there and hold the animals the
kids can be so traumatized different
that's doctor carries it on that carries
its own penalty sure so I'll see weird
dudes and who know what who knows what
else they're gonna happen that's six
zeros gonna be traumatized twenty years
twenty to forty many years for [ __ ]
animals III do think that might be a
little excessive am I wrong about this I
love dogs [ __ ] love I'm a dogs where
I have the problem I don't feel bad for
the dog the horses or that I don't
either
I don't either out or the coat
necessarily I wonder great for the goat
yeah what else you got a question on at
the so I've always heard that if you
walk behind a horse they always try to
kick you because you can't get behind
the now Center it's not true and how
high do you have today well kick the
[ __ ] Eddie if they don't want you around
if they don't see you you swore if they
don't if you just startled it or they
don't want you around the other
otherwise you can walk around if it's a
you know and how could they they have to
stand on something too right well yeah
they still what you ever seen mr. hands
I remember you very mr. hands I thought
that that was a horse boning the dude
the how you read that they created the
probably lift up the Sun he stood on
some detail now they [ __ ] yeah holy
cow sit lift the tail bull there's a
five man operation some dude just that
make sense yeah yeah what else you got
so Apple is currently facing a 1 billion
dollar lawsuit because there were a
string of thefts at different Apple
stores on the East Coast from
Massachusetts New Jersey and New York
City and they used facial recognition
from the security footage and caught one
person this I don't they don't specify
whether it's a guy or a girl but the
person that they arrested is originally
from New York and he said that he or she
said that they were actually at their
like school when this happened in New
York so they couldn't have had made all
the thefts at the different areas but
facial recognition from a third party
using apples I guess like technology
placed that person there but they
weren't there and so now Apple is saying
that they don't use facial recognition
to catch people in security footage but
they later backed up and said well we do
have the technology to use facial
recognition and we did have security
footage of it happening but we didn't
use our technology to find this person a
third party did it
what's weird I feel like I'm an episode
of [ __ ] CSI what's weird is that
Apple like there's like there's a murder
case or some [ __ ] and Apple won't give
you the access to break into their phone
like you just can't right we just can't
like you it it solves the murder like we
can't I guess not we just can't do that
right I find weird because if they do it
for that then that gives them a right to
do it for other things so we have to put
that rule in there like if they could
break into it with I they don't want to
mess
the great action of privacy yeah yeah
which ultimately probably the juice is
probably worth the squeeze at the end at
the end of the day yeah cuz how many
murders are being solved right although
they'll go back and listen to us like
with uh was it Alexis Alexa Alexa
they've gone back and listen to some
murders and like really ask because it
records or if there's a key word in a
pick up things and records it they've
used it solve crimes Danielle I heard
that happened with Xbox one as well what
a first came out yeah there's a voice
recognition system in that two brothers
listening but yeah my girl's dad bought
us Alexa and I was like absolutely not I
don't want to do it well there are ways
to do that with your phone they can turn
your phone into a mic I think something
happened to me yesterday too
I was planning to go to dinner this
weekend on a Friday with a girl no
family members cousins and stuff but I
was trying to apply it with my cousin's
oh the girl thing is disappointed family
is important and they're also not going
anywhere Chet I know my anyway so I I
was texting with my brother and my
cousins and then I got a Google
assistant email saying if you have
dinner plans on Friday something
something something I thought was like
way to quasi dental check like open
table or something like that no I
literally just text my brother and my
cousin I've heard this before I've heard
where they they it picks up on it said
dinner plans on Friday do this or do
that you know what sounds nice you mean
they're trying to help you out no that's
all the reservation rank their reasoning
if they're reading my text that's creepy
but I mean that's just could've been
coincidental or or not or not one fear
about sent a dick pic it's a lot if
you're gonna send that you should use
this bill your dad has sold all the time
to data brokers everything about you
baseball all that [ __ ] there's no
everything mmm and they did they trade
it and so that you become but is that is
that a lot is any of that different with
like podcast and they take this database
I mean listeners age location and these
advertisers use that it's all it's all
fine as long as it's within your consent
where the problem becomes is when you
fill something out of your doing
something or they're taking your data
and you don't even know it like they're
taking your shop
and everything and you don't know it
that can be an issue it's happening
you're sure it only gets worse from
there it doesn't get better so yeah why
it's definitely happening there yeah oh
yeah what else you get chin right here
Nicolas Cage he got married to his girl
of a he was dating her for like a year
this is Japanese chick he's hilarious
and then he was drunk and you should see
the video I'll play the video for you
soon they're in a courthouse in Las
Vegas trying to get married he's like
yeah she tried to get all my money he's
talking to other people in the crowd try
to get all my money he's drunk and she's
like I didn't tell you to do this I
didn't see how to do this anyways after
arguing the day of the wedding well as
you're in line in the courthouse to get
married to get their license astok so
then four days after or even before four
days he asked his lawyer to get an
annulment because he was a mistake
obviously all right he's hammered
hangover stuff and of course she says
she's fine with the annulment but she
needs spousal assess spousal support so
she's okay with the divorce but she's
requesting spousal support but they've
been together for a while four days a
year but married for less than for like
four days yeah is that her on the left
there no no no she's a I thought oh wow
Japanese grow great he's really super in
Asians and he's like notorious in k-town
he's awesome because he buys castles and
like nights and like cold swords and
Nazi gear and [ __ ] it's cool literally
the video please well that's his outfit
look at his hair amazing Belle such a
good actor god he's one of the best but
never has an end well after they got the
license dude they got an argument she
took off in a cab like literally as they
were leaving the courthouse yes her name
is Toph man ho look at her nervous so
he's probably completely bummed it's
just
that's him in the corner Sal takes her
face off just a drug dealer as a
boyfriend yeah he's talking about her
ex-boyfriend and this from daily No wow
they ended up do wrong
yeah they did get their I still decided
to go through it after this one let's go
come on romantic he looks so bummed that
romantic - dude him in leaving Las Vegas
oh my god what a brat
woman yeah yeah Wow it's not doing well
no well yeah that's him
no it's not what does Sheila see he does
a bunch of movies does a bunch of random
movie his movies you know he went broke
some are on demand had some real
problems for a while yeah he's buying
like cat straight up tasks oh yeah my
friends he's over here my good friend is
super good friends with him and I've
heard some really interesting stories
he's a great guy like white guy just
that access that insanity yeah it's
great
like what are you doing why are you
buying an emerald tree boa and why are
you buying caviar for what are you doing
like he's probably made a fortune to
afford just well the best actors of all
time yeah hilarious awesome but his hair
is tough man yeah man
all right this is a basketball why not
yeah is it basketball one that guy
Damian Lillard yeah
you scored eight buzzer winning yeah
buzzer game-winning three-pointer from
far away from downtown to put OKC away
yes and then there's a good video here
let me see
so it's just a win the playoff series
I'm sorry this is against whistle
Russell Westbrook's team - okay do it
win the playoffs yeah but check this off
to win the furthest air this series how
much time is left
it's two seconds
Oh beat the buzzer he's all the best
players than in there and then the way
he reacted is also funny to his face
yeah oh that is the deepest of threes
yeah and the guy hit it over Paul George
was like all right as a bad shot like he
all right he didn't have that shot
whenever he wants yeah did you're not
the best but you really don't give a
[ __ ] but it's cool he's a superbeing
stairs oh then the then Portland he'll
play the winner of Denver for San
Antonio so 50 points ten three-pointers
in the 37 foot game when he three play
he's a [ __ ] monster man Luke Walton
another basketball one yeah he's being
sued for sexual assault did you see the
girls case I saw the interview and it
looks super weird like skeptical super
sceptic yeah so she was she's known him
and his wife for a long time since they
played volleyball she played volleyball
with his wife or something a long time
ago when they're younger developed a
friendship with them and she was like
saying that he's sort of what do you got
those someone that you look after
someone's talking like your pupil but
not a mentor he was like a mentor to her
and then she was writing this book about
sports stars that turn that changed
their lives around and do something you
know normal look like what he's doing so
she asked him to write the foreword for
her book so she would visit him do
lunches with him constantly and then
finally when the book came out she found
out that he was part of the Lakers and
the Lakers are gonna be in town then she
asked him to meet up so she can give him
a book and he's like okay cool come to
the hotel she went to the hotel and he's
like oh so excited to see you keep our
key car over there and then come come
inside she said that she thought she was
gonna be in the lobby just talking to
him but yesterday coming to the room
Bobby yeah he's like I can't stand a lot
heat this is her excuse that she said he
said to her I can't hang out in the law
because I don't want the players to see
me so let's go up to their owners yes
and then a quarter in the room he threw
her to the bed held her down his kissed
her neck
her chest and stuff like that and
laughed at her when she said oh please I
want to go I want to go so no real
actual he made a pass at our clown seems
like it was a pass so should he lose his
job as the head coach of the Sacramento
Kings because of this and on top of that
after that incident like she was also
working as a charity on the board of a
charity thing so she had to ask him to
come by to do the speech so she went
downstairs to pick him up instead of
sending someone else after all this oh
wow and then talk about how good he is
and this and that she was upset about
having to do that and then she also was
that games showing like she would be
giving him hugs and she he would give
her a kiss on the cheek and she would
act all normal and fine she still was
killing her inside oh cool so is such a
weird story she said that's the get her
she's pretty hot socks so she definitely
sucks I mean I mean I don't know but it
just seems if you listen it seems yeah
it just seems a little scary
it's like that it's like that that that
Asian boxing journalist remember with
the Russian dude I am Russian do seal it
out so he got so he won his fight and
then kissed her lips right and then she
caused this big uproar not and so he
posted a video goes oh really where you
mad post picture of him in the club and
her sin next to like yo he convinced but
afterwards yeah sees you and me in the
club afterwards and they're super flirty
like so coming too bad oh but he got
suspended
he had suspended Bulgarian professional
boxer he got suspended man Wow he was
posted like Oh couldn't been too bad cuz
you went to my afterparty
we didn't ask you to come and you're
sitting next to me yeah yeah although
hey don't don't grab a woman and make
our there but that was the other those
dumb move down man super dumb dumb move
on both them I don't think you're a bad
people but let's run his lap right there
by the way but whatever she's on his lap
I can't tell
that clicky that he's posted something
really like he'll come on well she's
pretty hot to it super hot yeah they
seem to be all lovey-dovey she probably
had she probably got a big uproar and
then decided she had to make a stink
right I think she has super embarrassed
to like even if you are lovey-dovey like
that like like dude harrassing like she
can't let it she can't let him do that
I guess yeah you play erased it honey
probably take it down yeah he's
definitely in the wrong yeah but also
and I think yeah I think yes suspend in
California yeah I think she's fine but
you know if I did definitely should we
were I was being interviewed do that
you'd look at me go hey bro what the
[ __ ] he did like what ever from some
period like right off what else you got
Jen
alright test someone someone I think is
a Miss J sent this and he's following
the whole cat's feet stuff yeah so he
sent this in is actually a silicon feet
with built-in vaginas that you could buy
so there's vaginas in the ankle area as
if she's gonna [ __ ] the feet weird Wow
so cat could get a mold of her exactly
how bad how itself yeah
millionaires monkey no marks buddy look
at that can you imagine hey get your new
finally kid t-shirts kept your hip lines
also get your [ __ ] feet cat 9.99 this is
hilarious thanks Jesse you ever hear can
just think I wanna bust in her toes well
now you can so we got molds [ __ ]
that's so weird
let me bang the bones of the feet you
know so wrap off some feet and [ __ ]
though you know what we should do we
should create these sell them and then
call the cops on all the serial killers
you buy him I was gonna say that
couldn't be whose [ __ ] oh hello hello
hello what's going on here I don't know
a creepy new brothel dude what kind of
loser do you gotta be to go to sex
brothel with just robots I think it's
outrageous but can you tell me the exact
address Mike's playing is this an LA oh
it's not playing dude that guy's trying
to [ __ ] is he ever God Harry forums I
was gonna say those creepy chimneys
bots are from builders are comfortable
timber forearms that looks like a
chimpanzees forearm god I like how he's
trying to put her hair there you go yeah
contains scenes of adult nature yes
please fantastic hand me that Vaseline
over there please oh yeah you know where
your work is your work cut out cuz you
have clean all these things all the time
[Music]
do I have to call our harmony to Dwight
why the hair sense a little is the olive
honor sir boyfriend guarantee yeah or
just go to normal a brothel from
platinum braid okay my skin is supple
and firm my body is made for ultimate
pleasure and I can't wait for you to
feel it okay well I kind of feel like we
could have a really good time together
you might be right might even fall in
love well this crisis campaign you'll
help us open our first location in West
Hollywood California Wow it's close dude
let's go in there the robot dude uh yeah
whatever
it's just West Hollywood dad the fighter
and look you say what though you that
ladies are our money cuz she has to
[ __ ] power wash so space power wash
up dude and I want to know it'll
belgium's walk in there bus all of the
robot power wash those things I'd like
to know you know I'm saying or do they
just use like [ __ ] scoped mouthwash I
get bring right in elementary school
with the whistles
scope mouthwash you just dipped him in
that and that got rid of all the
diseases I saw jeez I wonder why
everyone got [ __ ] measles yeah yeah
really you just dip them in that and I
go get it was all tasty measles is no I
don't know whistles you never plays a
flute Oh
every quarter when they were just
dropping so mouthwash she just gave they
just dropped ours and mouthwash like
make sure you get one he's like let's
take it off and like blow it never
tasted sweet so I liked it yeah when we
think back on it this definitely or
maybe it is and you could do it with
these sex robots yeah dip them in
[ __ ] Listerine but then they don't
smell like humans disgust I would try it
out I would go there and watched it was
really expand when you have it when you
have a horn you blow into it like a
trumpet or whatever or like a harmonic I
mean or a clarinet the the reed will
stink if you don't clean it it starts
any insides - it's all saliva inside of
it be would you really go wood for the
experience for the other one these West
Hollywood sex robots yeah I don't think
I can get it up you know what you don't
know that yeah let's give it a go I find
out we don't think there's any way I can
get that get it up for that I don't know
I don't know like I don't see it either
and that does nothing for me when she
was like I want you to [ __ ] my mouth
alive girl who fluffed me and said [ __ ]
that robot is a warm-up that wouldn't
work for me I'm like well lit once you
just keep doing this so I have to [ __ ]
with a robot yeah that's a very strange
it's a form of necrophilia it's like a
weird I don't know try it out though you
know yes you just figured it out man
yeah I've never I've never I had a
flashlight for a while he gave me all
yeah somebody gave me two flashlights
his name abri Marcus well his name is
the soul is right Oh oaken will roam the
roads out rolling are we bad it was
sponsored by so he gave him to me he
didn't use him and I was like or maybe
he did use it once
I think he's talks about his pockets but
I just never knew I was like I'm not a
real stuff at all I don't know I just
chill would you go if I paid for you to
go so someone here can experience it if
it would you hell no especially not
these days why they're not gonna judge
you you know the girls aren't gonna
judge your body or let's show them all
yeah why did she wasn't really
live girl there's good-looking you do
that you won't shut up my life or the
dullness situation yeah gin you wouldn't
be down
I'm way to germaphobic come on dude
dude you're safer my friend wat than the
human there buy a brand new one would
you what's off ya woof is brand new
what if we played listen what robot
means does behave fishing videos in the
background or someone cooking fish I
know that gets read a card then you
could watch the fishing videos and bang
the robot I need sushi after it sounds
fun
still not into a good time you don't see
any guy robots do you just call dildos
you mean a guy robot cat hmm wow it was
like Jason Momoa and just like [ __ ]
you know if it looked close enough to
Jason Momoa maybe it depends on how I
look I'm sure you can get there probably
hmm looks weird but see girls do use
toys all the time right
guys don't so I think girls probably
more open to it no I mean the thing with
the robot is that it'd be nice to
eliminate personality hey scroll up to
oh is this pool I want a robot who well
58% love me unconditionally well it's a
robot so you know whatever you said it
to do the household chores or teach me
new things only one hundred thirteen
votes though you know teach me seven
likes Wow he's kind of expressive eyes
looks like a beautiful gay man a strong
jaw and big eyes is universe it looks
like Brian if he's in Sim City love that
Murray so you're thinking of Sin City
that's a great movie I said Sim City the
video game oh yeah it's a good thing
what else you got Marshawn Lynch
retiring it says again but this time it
says uh for good good for him
I saw I was in San Francisco I hung out
with him such a good guy I thought he
was fat before but I didn't realize he's
actually like
look you
got on him though in the offseason but
he's a straight-up freak yeah whoa let's
pray feel yeah we gotta give him his
belt where's his belt out there I got
like [ __ ] ten minutes oh hey Nick
it's Nick supporting everybody at the
Hong Kong in actually the 30th of this
month
come on over Nick what's up bro
come on oh no I do not like that man we
thought it's [ __ ] Jason Momoa dude
don't be so aggressive man you're
missing your legs like a gangster I did
not know you can try this you can't sue
me
oh yeah you can't no you have to do the
Hong Kong in the 30th what's going on
not much what are you doing man oh my
gosh hurt me you don't even have a
[ __ ] operator Mike oh man damn it
Nick you ruin everything
hey guys here the crew goes who the fire
kid have on let's get on our show tell
me tell me what's going on Nick Swardson
well talking in the Mike [ __ ] talk in
the mic Pro him and Brian at the Hong
Kong in oh really dirty
oh you look horrible for me and I was
here bro good lips that bill man this is
real friendship Brian and Brendan do you
guys look like the COO this is America
bro [ __ ] black yarn black what do you
got some Egyptians from we're 19
different colors and you had like a
bouncer at a TGI Fridays and be
confident right
oh you look like the Patrick Swayze
without a pancreatic cancer look at Nick
Sam look at Nick's [ __ ] socks look at
the tastic collar me clothes like you
robbed a hot polish O'Brien like your
rosacea free that if you watch the
episodes I'm just chilling yeah Brian's
got this wild capillaries you look good
today brother
Wow capillaries I was told I look
healthy you got a Sirica keeping things
tight right bro he got blue eyes guys
you notice that I can't fold they match
one of my Nick folds over here yes
you're very blue doubt right now yeah
the great GQ and I'm blue we can't all
be a [ __ ] Pizza Delivery mime
Hartford assisted Oh where's your board
you get that chain from chucky cheese
and [ __ ] fire island [ __ ] gypsy at
the fire festivals right you look
[ __ ] you've played for the Sandlot
team this lob dyrdek bro the guy looks
like a [ __ ] raccoon dipped in Gary
Busey's dick sweat oh Jesus
like Brendan looks so bad I got 11th
degree burns I'm upside that's what
Brian washes his face with my Quivers
empty Wow damn dude good luck car pool
with Brian out of the Hong Kong here
I'll Drive my test loud there you've
been in a real Tesla I have it Brian all
right my hands go to Rome
I'm excited yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
gonna take care of the kid you can take
care of the old Bob Kahn as I Drive
looks like a like the new rookie on the
Billy Ray Cyrus's your spirit animal
whatever Marshawn Lynch died retired
father how dare you oh yeah
way to bring it down he looks like he
Shops at us like with a skill crane bro
everything you eat a Hut prized
aquariums dude Nick what how about your
Viking sucked ass though boom [ __ ]
Italian Lego Cape Bergen
you gotta coach the kids up oh yeah I
think of that thirty know Kenna's pants
back [ __ ] socks back drop illegal
Malakand dope did I enjoy my life just
if you'll travel he goes to tropical
places yeah dude what's up man what's
your favorite place to go I feel like
actually I really enjoyed India the
other way [ __ ] yeah dude I'm all right
we got a dip out we're gonna do a
podcast yeah we're gonna do a podcast
man I'll do a podcast it's gonna talk
about you can't talk about here we're
gonna talk about the Hong Kong in May
30th it's put it on as MySpace and we'll
see what happens yeah we're doing
podcast next door I know what do you
guys do you guys do um what is it when
you sell all the necklaces and stuff
late at night on television you stay
here QVC yeah don't say that you see
this QVC it looks like it yeah no man we
got your QVC you selling a QVC belt Punk
is this a belt that's the belt man oh
wow only took seven months to get your
I've been around with uh Dustin Poirier
fake belt that's the real thing there
bro this is it huh that's it man I won
this Nick that's good good for your
deserving yeah
Nick was up for the award too you know
wow this looks like the [ __ ]
healthiest thing in Reno
rose real-man do this weighs 70 pounds
more than the other one man Wow oh my
god that's half of Brendan's head Dana
White made that my hand notice the back
Python what's up Nick what up bro
oh that's python skin huh oh sorry
Siegfried Android oh that's real fun
baby that's real [ __ ] gone baby
that's what's up they all dope that pen
man thank you guys man welcome you don't
run this honor
I got it running Stimpy get out here man
bro relax you bye guys Congrats on your
culottes afoot the Hong Kong in just
three given that in this case comes with
it oh wow there's a beautiful case the
holster brother come to the carrying
those shorts are aggressive culottes oh
well very unique style yeah very unique
I have style
he was like you own every yellow wolf
yellow is a [ __ ] champ bro don't [ __ ]
with Nick any reason [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] legend bro yeah there's a Viper
man damn dude oh yeah there's a woman
who I know there is a strapless dactyl
son but she looks legit welcome to strap
gana stand baby saying I got two and if
you want them the right next door I'm
gonna get Michael rapper warts gum from
under this [ __ ] table dude Julie's
gonna be pissed let him get pissed bro
in his mansion dude okay what he can't
buy is too mother [ __ ] belts baby
graduation
bro it's an X let's take you on the
roads guest starring starring Nick
Swardson and Theo von
very nice there will be the eight okay
you know what I'm saying
given a J's bro see at the Hong Kong
what is the HK I'm sorry okay somebody
do a guest spot later boys bye guys see
sweet guys bye bunny bear April 30th
Hong Kong and me and Nick Swardson and
Chara Gary takes
I gotta go dudes hilarious yeah Nick's
hilarious did you have this woman who
woke up from a coma after 30 years
oh well let's bring the show to a
screeching halt after that hilarious
piss knowing about us
that was funny man yeah it was um well I
gotta get outta here dude Phoenix this
Friday Saturday 2 shows Friday to show
Saturday VIP is sold out get your
general mission ticket stand-up live
Felix Friday Saturday after that I'm in
Tampa Bay Tampa they call Tampa Bay just
Tampa Tampa I think I'll call it a
baker's Tim Bay Buccaneers yeah I think
it's just I used to call Tampa Bay me
too it's Tampa tip improv either way May
10th through the 11th I'm in Cleveland
dropping some cleveland steamers
cleveland t5k calm for tickets B we're
gonna be at as you asked buddy Denver
that show I believe that Late Show
Thursday sold out they may still have
some tickets what I understand they
wanted to add a third show Saturday not
doing exciting up in the hospital s time
get your tickets if there are any left
Miami may 9 10 11 still tickets left get
your tickets and Miami improv may 9 10
11 Orlando may 17 and 18 I'll see out
there kids much love love you guys this
the fun kid were out